politics often feels a long way away
from places like charlestown
but not anymore this bastion of
conservatism
is still processing what has provoked a
national emergency
but for donald trump's faithful
supporters he's been framed as the bad
guy
by a corrupt media and political elite
you know he didn't not inciting violence
in portland is he
or other places talking about what
happened well i know but that's a yeah
but
it's it all yeah did he incite the
violence no i don't think he
no i don't think he incited the violence
really i don't
he was getting people together he was
trying to you know i do i think the
election was stolen absolutely
donald trump has fanned and legitimized
extremist views throughout his term
this was the president at a rally in
2018 surrounded by q and non-conspiracy
theorists
who believe only he can save the country
the most virulent symptoms of trumpism
exist to a large extent online
and it is the supporters there who are
now pushing a narrative
that the violence in the capital was
actually orchestrated
by far-left extremists now we're coming
to
be able to compare photos and videos of
individuals
wearing maga gear and
identify them cross-reference them to
previous antifa
previous black life matters so you're
saying that the known extremists the
ones that we know
are right-wing extremists were actually
not those extremists at all they were in
disguise
that sounds quite i'm saying is the
agitators
were not right-wing extremists it is
through the looking-glass stuff but the
evidence it was his supporters
inspired or incited by their
commander-in-chief
is overwhelming as they were rampaging
through the capitol buildings
donald trump initially refused to
condemn them
with the threat of impeachment and
prosecution growing
he soon changed his tune this was a
fraudulent election
but we can't play into the hands of
these people
we have to have peace so go home
we love you you're very special to those
who engage in the acts of violence and
destruction
you do not represent our country and to
those who broke the law
you will pay for some trump supporters
there is disappointment he's now
acknowledged joe biden
will be the next u.s president but the
question is
as america faces a major constitutional
crisis
what becomes of the movement he started
in the years to come
alex rossi sky news west virginia